bienvenidos a este programa especial de
france 24 en el que vamos a analizar el
año más difícil para jair bolsonaro el
presidente de brasil que ha perdido
mucha popularidad hace tan sólo un año
el 39 por ciento de los brasileños le
apoyaba y es a pesar de las polémicas
sobre su gestión de la pandemia de el
coronavirus pero con el aumento
descontrolado de las muertes y los
retrasos en el arranque de la vacunación
su popularidad se ha desplomado y hoy
tan sólo el 29 por ciento de los
brasileños le apoya frente al 65 por
ciento que le rechaza abiertamente
además el ex presidente de brasil luiz
inácio lula da silva es el claro
favorito en los sondeos de precampaña
con un 48 por ciento de intención de
voto y esto a pesar de que ni siquiera
ha formalizado su candidatura la
popularidad de bolsonaro ha caído no
sólo por la situación sanitaria sino
también por la crisis económica hay una
inflación muy alta por encima del 10% y
13,5 millones de parados que sitúan a
brasil en el cuarto lugar del ranking
mundial de desempleo
con algunos electores de bolsonaro y nos
han contado en el próximo reportaje que
se han arrepentido
en río de janeiro hay mil 74 favelas en
2018 jair bolsonaro triunfo en todas
ellas
maría vive desde hace 30 años en vila
kennedy una favela del suburbio que
abriga a más de 100.000 personas
[Música]
el alta de los precios ha hecho mella en
su economía está 6a solidaria va a
proporcionarle un pequeño alivio
hace tres años maría botto por bolsonaro
porque creyó en su honestidad hoy está
decepcionada por la gestión de la
pandemia
hizo poco caso a las personas dijo que
el cob y era una simple gripe cita
muchas personas murieron y no hicieron
nada no ofrecieron nada elijamos pero
él ha demostrado que no es una persona
cualificada para dirigir un país
yo creo que evolucionar o no va a ganar
en las favelas yo particularmente siento
que dentro de estos territorios existe
un sentimiento de frustración en
relación a todas las expectativas que
creó el nuevo gobierno pero no
uno de cada tres electores de bolsonaro
quería evitar el regreso de la izquierda
de lula y acabar con la corrupción
es el caso de este economista que se
arrepintió
los resultados están allí la inflación
por las nubes una de las más altas del
mundo el real es una de las monedas que
más se desvalorizó en el mundo y la tasa
de paro en brasil es una de las más
altas del mundo yo no le voy a votar
porque ya ha demostrado que no es un
político honesto ni tampoco competente
en la competencia más están yendo
frente a la actual polarización política
un tercio de los electores podría optar
por la tercera vía representada por
sergio moro el juez anticorrupción que
encarceló a lula 20
y todavía es pronto el juego acaba de
comenzar creo que mucha agua va a correr
en las cosas más probable es que esta
polarización lula evolucionar o a lo
mejor no se produzca en 2022
el presidente perdió mucho peso
electoral y lula está en la delantera
pero es porque la campaña todavía no
empezó con
eso
también es difícil prever qué peso
tendrán las más de 615 mil muertes por
kobe de aquí a un año
en un intento de remontar en las
encuestas personas ha creado un nuevo
subsidio para los más pobres que
substituye la 'bolsa familia' el famoso
programa social de la era de lula que
benefició a 44 millones de brasileños el
nuevo programa se llama auxilio brasil
es un cheque de 400 reales unos 70
dólares es decir el doble que la bolsa
familia para probarlo ha sido necesario
revisar el techo de gasto público
establecido por el anterior gobierno y
esto deja en entredicho la credibilidad
de la política fiscal de brasil frente a
los inversores extranjeros
además varios politólogos creen que esas
medidas de corte populista no son
garantía de éxito para los comicios del
año que viene y de hecho cree en esos
mismos analistas que lula y bolsonaro
sólo ganan si ambos llegan al segundo
turno porque ambos se benefician de la
crispación que se vive en brasil hay un
nuevo contrincante en el escenario
político el ex juez sergio moro de
momento también precandidato que se
presenta como el gran pacificador de
brasil
falta un año para los comicios de 2022 y
todo puede pasar en un país que tiene
una frágil memoria colectiva
muchas gracias por seguir esta emisión
especial desde río de janeiro y sigan
nuestra programación en france24 en
español